[Music]
hey guys do you ever see certain things
that certain men do in public places
areas
that just makes you go oh man i can't
believe that guy just did that
well today i'm gonna talk about some of
these things and hopefully some of these
guys are watching this video and then
they will change their ways and
hopefully we can make this world a
little bit better to live in so let's
start with number one
not washing your hands before you leave
the toilet
i mean do i really need to say anything
here
well i do because a lot of guys are not
self-aware but if women knew how many
guys did this they would really not let
men any men touch them because the
number of men i've seen just leaving the
toilet without washing their hands
is the majority and it is it's
disgusting think about it it's
disgusting you do your business you what
your hands are touching you know
personal stuff and you just walk out
like that
and then if you do go and wash it you
know some of these guys they wash it and
then they do this you know and then you
stand right next to them you're washing
your hands and you feel this the
splatter all over you don't do that as
well
picking your nose i mean that's just
gross doing that in public
that's one of the reasons why i never
like to really greet guys handshake you
know i'd rather prefer a fist bump
because i never know what they are doing
with their hands so picking your nose in
public area is a big no-no and also
picking your ears i mean some guys you
talk to them that you have a
conversation with them and they they do
this
i mean that's disgusting go home go to a
toilet or take a shower and take care of
your hygiene
showing off your muscles
i mean you know those guys who just try
to show off their muscles to look more
cool more manly you know
i mean i know some of us we do it just
as a joke but there are actually some
guys who really do it because they want
to look cool and strong manly for some
reason i mean we used to do it when we
were kids but some guys they never grow
up
you know another thing that i see a lot
is guys on the beach you know they walk
and they're like they check out their
abs you know or their muscles like this
stop doing that
everyone can see what you're doing
it really looks silly true confidence is
not i need to impress everyone it's
knowing that you don't have to
clean
your toilet seat
i mean would you do that at home
that's just crazy you go to public areas
and then you don't clean your toilet
seat you know
i'm not a guy who i don't want to go to
public toilets but there are times when
you need to go when your body wants to
go you need to go and do your thing so
you rush you go to the toilet you get
there you're like yes i'm here and then
it's fully like oh and you start to
panic and then finally someone opens the
door and you're like yes and then as
soon as you want to go in
you're reminded that
man i hope this place is clean and you
connect with the guy you go in you watch
him eye to eye and you think to yourself
man i hope this guy cleaned after
himself
and then you go and you see this pee all
over the toilet
i mean really
that's disgusting come on man
if you are one of those guys who do this
that's disgusting shame on you you're a
selfish person
swearing
you know if you swear in public places
then you're really not self-aware
especially family-friendly places like
them mall i mean imagine this i walk
with my little nieces nephews in the
mall they're so innocent right young
kids and then a group of guys walk past
they swear they talk these vulgar words
that's just even too vulgar for me to
even think about it's a family-friendly
place and then those little kids they
are forced
to hear what you are saying i mean
that's gross and you know it always
surprises me that there are these group
of guys who think it's cool they are
cooler or better if they swear
it's actually showing that you have low
self-esteem
because if you believe that you need to
use swear words every second word is a
crutch word is a swear word that you use
to try and look cooler or better sound
better means that you don't have enough
confidence in yourself just to talk
normally without swear words it's
actually sad
and you will lose a lot of respect from
a lot of people especially in a work
environment playing loud music
you know those
those guys who play loud music in their
cars you can hear it from five blocks
away i mean that's just so disrespectful
right because it's selfish you are
forcing everyone to listen to your
choice of music
while somebody is just they just want to
have a nice day so you take their piece
away the same thing happens late at
night you know imagine a father who
works two jobs really hard to support
his family he's tired he gets home he's
he's not been sleeping good for the last
week because he's been working so hard
and he's looking forward to this one day
for example a sunday that he can just go
and rest and just as he closes his eyes
on the bed he hears
man this happened to me a few times even
where i live now we have a crazy
neighbor here who sometimes he just
doesn't have any respect for other
people so selfish and it makes you want
to stand up and go do something
but
i'm a christian
god calms me down so i don't do anything
silly but if you are one of those guys
just be considerate think about your
neighbors think about other people stop
being selfish
talking too
loud you know this happens especially at
restaurants you know when you when you
plan that special evening that date with
your wife i mean your schedule is so
busy you only have that one day and you
prepare for you you look forward to it
the whole week and then it arrives and
then you go and you're happy you just
sit down and actually want to enjoy
a nice evening these guys in your right
they just start laughing loud swearing
cursing they just talk loud and they
don't care about anyone but themselves
just mind your manners
be more self-aware and just be a decent
human being
stop with the tough guy you know
whenever i see a guy trying to act all
tough and strong and
i just want to walk away i mean really
the worst thing is when there's a group
of guys together and all of them are
trying to prove that they are the alpha
male i mean i'm it's just
it's so childish it honestly is childish
someone who is puffed up boastful
arrogant is just actually insecure it is
silly and childish i call it plain
maniki syndrome in afrikaans my language
to try and translate it little guy
syndrome
it's not a good translation the correct
meaning doesn't get across but it's just
like yeah it's actually a little guy
mentality in english the translation is
little guy mentality a small mind
you know the most men that i admire
that are self-confident they are never
arrogant or boastful they are always
humble
never praise yourself in front of other
people let other people do it
every social interaction that you have
is not a contest to see who has the best
education career car house or the most
money in fact just that need that you
feel that you need to boast about
things about your life even material
things things that you've achieved
actually shows that you need the
approval of other people to feel better
about yourself
that is not true confidence true
confidence is knowing who you are and
you don't need other people's approval
now if you want to check out some other
self-improvement videos then check out
these ones here and i'll see you there
and always remember life is short so
don't waste yours cheers guys